black lives matter which is what this
movement is supposedly about should be
an honorable movement and so Zak I guess
if you want to put up the screen one
more time here's here's their actual
website this is the what we believe page
of the black lives matter website and
you scroll down a little bit and
basically they've got I have to find it
sorry here we are that's near the top we
are unapologetically black in our
positioning in affirming that black
lives matter we need not qualify our
position to love and desire freedom and
justice for ourselves is a prerequisite
for wanting the same for others I'm on
board with that that that seems
acceptable to me especially the first
sentence we are unapologetically black
in our positioning it's black lives
matter as it should be but they're lying
this isn't what they then do look down
this list and find that we have no
goodness where now it's up here we make
space right below this close to the top
of the list we make space for
transgender brothers and sisters to
participate and lead we're self
reflexive and do the work required to
dismantle cisgender privilege and uplift
black trans folks especially black trans
women again and then the next one oh we
build a space that affirms black women
final in a list of three when women make
up half of the population and actual
trans people make up a tiny tiny
fraction of one percent and then finally
we make our spaces family-friendly and
enable parents to fully participate with
their children awesome oops we dismantle
the patriarchal practice that requires
mothers to work double shifts so they
can mother in private even as they
participate in public justice work I
don't I'm not sure exactly what that's
referring to but the very next one is we
disrupt the Western proscribed nuclear
family structure requirement by
supporting each other as exam families
and villages how keep going collectively
care for one another especially our
children to the degree that mothers
parents and children are comfortable
mothers parents and children a phrase a
number of people have point
is carefully constructed to exclude
fathers they could be included under
parents but they are not specifically
labeled there for a reason and the idea
that dismantling the nuclear family is
in any way centering black lives when
it's so clearly destructive of all lives
but actually historically and right now
specifically destructive of black lives
in America shows that this is not what
it seems
yeah you can take it off it's not what
it seems so there is a lot to the
question of what trans is doing here and
why trans Trant black trans women is
playing the specific role that it is so
conspicuously evergreen was not a
especially diverse campus racially
racially right it had only 4,000
students total hmm
the protest was involved a couple
hundred people who were very actively
involved three leaders may be the three
leaders were maybe eight leaders right
maybe maybe I would say a couple hundred
say the three leaders who showed up
again and again were black trans women
you know the term that at least two of
them use for themselves or bloc
transplant last trans femme so anyway
there's just something demographically
conspicuous about that right there's
something about people who are born male
who transition to female and are black
who are somehow at the very forefront of
this movement despite their tiny tiny
numbers this is to the exclusion even to
the extent that there's all of this very
positive sounding language about
supporting these trans people this is
also to the exclusion of trans people
who aren't black and it is to the
exclusion of trans men who are born
female and ultimate transition male so
in some sense one of the things that's
going on here is that there's a trick of
the mind right to say we are protecting
black trans women women is a protected
class because women have a built-in
disadvantage least strength
wise and also historically power wise so
people who are born into that advantage
and then move into a protected class are
a phenomenon we have to talk about right
what is the proper mental reaction to
this right is it to take the protections
that we ordinarily reserved for women
and to give them to anyone born male who
simply says you know what I'm female and
if so do you expect anybody to take
advantage of that opportunity who is not
doing so on the basis that they are
internally of this mind set so I will of
course there will be people who take
advantage and of course if there is no
hurdle to be jumped beyond claiming now
I'm a woman of course there will be
people who game that and we have seen it
yep I would also point out that the it
was a gigantic rally in New York I can't
remember if I showed it on the I don't
think you Todd caste but it was a
gigantic rally in New York and basically
as far as I can tell
second to the hashtag black lives matter
and in terms of the protest priorities
was black trans lives matter was the
hashtag and so why if the idea is that
this is all people who face oppression
why would you limit that to black trans
lives why wouldn't it just be trans
lives matter as a fellow traveler
honestly I mean if if we were to take
them at their word and say that this is
an objection to police brutality and the
continuing in justices in the courts and
certainly historically racially in jest
laws which demographic within black
people has suffered the most its young
black men mmm right it's young you know
black women like all black people have
suffered at the hands of racist
ideologies in certainly historical and
to some extent modern us but who has
suffered the most within black people
it's black men and why then why then are
we talking why then are they focused on
a demographic that is so tiny and so new
but actually has a history with policing
and the
that can't probably extend back into
even into the 20th century
so at some level it has something to do
with the fact that you know this
mentality this intersectional mentality
creates an unassailable 'ti right the
unassailable attea pens to the number of
categories that you can add together
that you can say are having an emergent
effect and there's you know it we were
talking earlier about the the fact that
these words don't function like normal
words that they actually function like
mechanisms that force you into
acknowledgment that the whole slate of
claims is right and you know this is
another set like how do you wade into
these waters about transness I mean
we're watching you know JK Rowling get
into very hot water for saying very
reasonable things about the need to
continue to protect women and that
transness does not invalidate that need
so anyway the waters are so fraught that
nobody can figure out how to navigate
them which is creating a juggernaut well
it doesn't it doesn't strike me as any
sort of a concerted conspiracy but the
ability for people to make the claim
that they were trans absent intention or
actual follow-through with regard to
hormonal or surgical modification and
obvious gender dysphoria body gender
dysphoria
and having you know most of the liberal
intelligentsia and mainstream media and
academia say oh of course if you say so
yes was even if not part originally of
the movement that became black lives
matter
certainly it is clear the black lives
matter observed that and said ah that
worked what is it that we can do that
can get people to roll over and accept
these things that sound like if you
don't agree with them you must be a
nasty human being that's how it's that's
how it's being done right now because
although until you know until ten years
ago no one had ever heard of transphobia
and in fact
Sophia is not what it sounds like but no
one wants to be called a racist no one
wants to be called a misogynist no one
wants to be called a transphobic cept
transphobia is so clearly not what it
means it doesn't have the historical
manifestation that that racism does and
so people at first like oh I am alright
gosh that's terrible I don't but you
know I have compassion for trans people
and of course what transphobia at the
point that you're accused of transphobia
often what it means is that you are
making the you know apparently
outrageous but actually biologically
real and foundational claim that sex is
real and that we have an uninterrupted
history of sexual dimorphism and sexual
reproduction for 500 million years you
know that's what that's what I mean when
I say sex is real and that is the moment
when I have been called a trans foe
well transphobes a tripwire it's not a
word as a tripwire and there are several
of them transphobic is anything that
suggests any kind of skepticism about
any claim made within a half a mile of
transness of any kind
mm-hmm you've got turf trans
exclusionary radical feminists which is
the claim that you are in fact some kind
of you are pushing some kind of
aggressive ideology to have any doubt at
all that all protections normally
awarded to women should be necessarily
awarded to two men who transition to
female which includes you know not just
you know if a fully transitioned trans
woman what is her situation with regard
to public bathrooms and I say fully
transitioned in contrast to someone
who's put on a dress and declared that
because they like the color pink they're
a woman because no they're not but all
the way over here to if you've declared
yourself a woman you get to you get to
compete against women in sport yeah
which frankly that is the reversal of
the honest and wonderful part of title 9
like title 9 happened in order to allow
women to compete in sport and to get
some funds to do so and allowing men who
declared themselves women even if
they've been on hormones
if they went through development as men
they should not be competing against
women in sport they shouldn't be it's
not there yeah and it is the back door
on invention of legal structure is
designed to protect a class it's the
unprotected of a class of people who
were protected for in this case physical
reasons now you just said to me
yesterday about the intentional
unprotected of Li the unhooking of some
legal structures in California
what was this oh jeez it was now I don't
know how serious this effort is but
there was a where there is a ballot
proposition to remove the prohibition
against discrimination based on race sex
gender identity so that obviously opens
a frightening door but before we leave
the the trans question so you've got
transphobic einde of all purpose you've
got turf you've got trans medical astray
um which as far as I can tell her it's
not on my cell why they have a settled
list and trans gum well sex shop and
shows it's like Chopin casters so
there's an inability to resolve even the
label on these things meaningfully but
what that one means is that if you are a
person who believes that true transness
requires dysphoria then you are also of
some sort of radical belief system and
that really there is no threshold that
would define the difference between true
trans and anything else and the real
point is look you could make all these
arguments but what's really being said
is you are not under any circumstances
allowed to make any counter-argument or
express any skepticism and this is going
to be a hallmark of this entire movement
[Music]